Quien dice que en las dictaduras nunca hay
elecciones, se equivoca.
¿Queréis un ejemplo? Este pasado domingo
3 de diciembre los venezolanos - aunque todavía
no puedas elegir libremente su gobierno - fueron
llamados a votar en un referéndum sobre una
supuesta causa común:
La Guyana Esequiba.
(Venezuela sostiene desde hace más de 100
años una disputa territorial con Guyana El
pequeño país vecino que en los últimos
años ha hecho grandes descubrimientos de
petróleo
Está en discusión la soberanía de 159.542
km, lo que representa el 74,21% del territorio
guyanés. Y para fijar su posición, el gobierno
venezolano organizó un referéndum. El resultado,
por supuesto, era previsible: el 90% apoyaron
la tesis que ahora defiende el gobierno chavista.
Esto es, intentar recuperar la Guyana Esequiba.
¿Qué esperabais? )
A pesar de ser una disputa que viene ya de
muy lejos, en los últimos meses el gobierno
chavista ha llevado a cabo una escalada como
hacía mucho tiempo no se veía sobre este
tema… La tensión está al rojo vivo.
Y ojo porque no hablamos de una apelación
judicial ni nada por el estilo, sino de auténticos
tambores de guerra.
N1(13 de noviembre de 2023: Maduro desempolva
el reclamo sobre la soberanía venezolana
en la Guayana Esequiba. El País)
N2(23 de noviembre de 2023: Lula quiere evitar
una guerra entre Venezuela y Guyana y manda
a un hombre de confianza a mediar. LaPoliticaOnline)
Queridos amigos, amigas, así están las cosas.
El aparato del Estado ha promocionado la votación
con vallas, conciertos, merchandising, concentraciones
militares y publicidad incesante en redes
sociales.
(Según el gobierno algo más de 10 millones
de venezolanos acudieron a votar, de los cuales
más del 90% votaron a favor de la reivindicación
territorial del Esequibo que está llevando
a cabo el gobierno. El aparato del Estado
promocionó la votación con vallas, conciertos,
merchandising, concentraciones militares y
un montón de publicidad en redes sociales.
Pero pese a todo, la cifra resulta difícil
de creer. Los colegios estuvieron prácticamente
vacíos. Pero esto es Venezuela, amigos. Sea
como sea, ahora el régimen chavista tiene
un nuevo comodín bajo el brazo.)
El caso es que toda esta sorprendente tensión
que ahora se ha desatado repentinamente en
torno a la relación guyanesa-venezolana nos
lleva a hacernos varias preguntas.
¿Qué pretende exactamente el régimen chavismo
con este referéndum? ¿Por qué tanto interés
de repente por esta cuestión? ¿Cómo de
probable es que pueda estallar un conflicto
armado en el Esequibo?
Pues… Todo esto y más lo vamos a ver a
continuación.
Gasolina y ¡Arranquemos!
Para entender cómo y cuándo nace este conflicto
tenemos que remontarnos hasta la era de las
colonias. Concretamente, cuando Guyana estaba
bajo el control del Imperio Británico y Venezuela
del Imperio español.
La Guyana esequiba formaba parte de la Capitanía
General de Venezuela, un dominio español
creado por Carlos III en el año 1777. Sin
embargo, la primera intromisión en la zona
no fue británica, sino holandesa. Fueron
los neerlandeses los que, ante la falta de
control efectivo de Madrid, plantaron las
primeras colonias no españolas en la región.
(Sin embargo, tras una serie de guerras y
enfrentamientos, los holandeses muy debilitados
perdieron el control de sus asentamientos
y los británicos se convirtieron en los gobernadores
de facto en 1796. Poco después, el tratado
Anglo-Holandés de 1814 y el Congreso de Viena
en 1815 dieron como resultado que las colonias
de Esequibo, Demerara, y Berbice fueron cedidas
oficialmente al Reino Unido.
Así nacio la Guayana Británica, que colindaba
en el oeste con la recién nacida Venezuela.
Además, en paralelo a la posesión británica
de Guyana, Caracas logró su independencia
de España.
El problema es que los límites entre ambos
territorios no estaban nada claros. Por eso,
en 1841 la Royal Geographical Society contrató
a Robert Hermann Schomburgk, un naturalista
alemán, para que trazara las fronteras de
la Guyana Británica tanto con Venezuela en
su parte oeste, como con la Guyana Neerlandesa,
hoy Surinam, en el este.
Este estudio terminó estableciendo la conocida
como línea Schomburgk, una frontera que efectivamente
le dio 80.000 km² adicionales a la Guayana
Británica. Pensad que antes de la determinación
de esta línea era el Río Esequibo la frontera
natural entre ambos territorios.)
Pues bien, es precisamente este tramo, el
que podemos encontrar entre Río Esequibo
y la línea Schomburgk lo que hoy ha disparado
la tensión política e, incluso, militar
entre Georgetown y Caracas.
Y la pregunta es ¿por qué nunca se ha logrado
alcanzar una solución? ¿De verdad que en
170 años nunca se ha logrado aclarar la situación
de la zona? ¿En qué se basa ahora el chavismo
para lanzar una reivindicación tan agresiva?
Pues para entenderlo, tenemos que dar un pequeño
repaso a los libros de historia. ¡Atentos!
(T1: DE LAS TRAMPAS JUDICIALES AL ESCENARIO
BÉLICO)
Tras sellar su independencia en 1821, y con
la muerte de Simón Bolívar hacia 1830, Venezuela
entró en un espiral de violencia interna,
cuando varios caudillos locales buscaron hacerse
del control del país. Fue, justo en ese momento,
cuando se dibujó la línea Schomburgk, de
tal forma que cuando las cosas se calmaron
en Caracas, el británico al oeste del Esequibo
ya era un hecho.
Hacia 1880, el entonces presidente venezolano,
Antonio Guzmán Blanco, comenzó a denunciar
a nivel internacional la intromisión británica,
hasta el punto de que en 1895 el tema se coló
en la mismísima agenda de la Casa Blanca.
C1(“La disputa ha llegado a una etapa tal
que hace que ahora incumba a los Estados Unidos
tomar medidas para determinar con suficiente
certeza cuál es la verdadera línea divisoria
entre la República de Venezuela y la Guayana
Británica.” Presidente Grover Cleveland,
17 de diciembre de 1895.)
El mensaje del presidente norteamericano obligó
a Londres a tener que aceptar un laudo arbitral
internacional. Y en febrero de 1897, Venezuela,
Estados Unidos y Gran Bretaña, llegaron a
un acuerdo para concretar el desarrollo de
un proceso judicial que dirimiera de una vez
por todas la disputa territorial. Sin embargo,
la palabra “acuerdo” no es lo más ideal
para describir la posición venezolana.
(Una de las reglas acordadas por Washington
y Londres contemplaba dejar a Venezuela fuera
de la conformación del tribunal arbitral,
al tiempo que la defensa del país sudamericano
en el juicio quedaría en manos de abogados
estadounidenses. De esta forma, Caracas fue
un mero espectador en torno al proceso judicial
que se desarrolló en París en 1899. Un juicio
donde una parte no está siquiera presente.
El tribunal compuesto por dos británicos,
dos estadounidenses y un ruso -como juez neutral-
determinó que la línea Schomburgk sí conformaba
la frontera real entre Venezuela y Guyana,
legitimando, por tanto, el dominio británico
al oeste del río Esequibo.
Eso sí, a Venezuela se le otorgó, quizás
como una cierta compensación, la soberanía
de las bocas del río Orinoco, un enclave
estratégico pero, por supuesto, mucho más
limitado que la reclamación venezolana.)
Y la pregunta es, ¿cómo se justificó este
fallo judicial? Pues 100 años después aún
no está claro. Los motivos de la resolución
judicial nunca fueron publicados y por eso
desde entonces Venezuela considera la ocupación
británica como una usurpación.
Más tarde, en la década de los 50s, Venezuela
experimentó un importante crecimiento económico
bajo la dictadura de Marcos Pérez Jiménez,
un tipo que años después de ser derrocado
hizo público que el país sudamericano ha
mantenido durante décadas planes para recuperar
militarmente el territorio
del Esequibo.
(Pero la cosa no se quedó ahí. En 1962 Venezuela
comenzó a reclamar ante las Naciones Unidas
que se considerará nulo en Laudo Arbitral
de 1899 ante las sospechas de que en la resolución
se quiso favorecer los intereses británicos.
El resultado es que en 1966 Venezuela y Reino
Unido aceptaron buscar un nuevo mecanismo
que sustituyera el laudo arbitral de París.
El problema es que esto sucedió apenas unas
pocas semanas antes de que Londres le concediera
la independencia a Guyana. A partir de ese
momento las conversaciones tendrían que ser
entre Caracas y Georgetown. Y, claro, aunque
el acuerdo alcanzado entre Londres y Caracas
contemplaba un plazo máximo de 4 años para
que las partes se pusieran de acuerdo, en
el nuevo gobierno de Guyana no querían saber
nada de ese tema. Al final la situación quedó
estancada con algún que otro altercado militar
entre medias.)
Pero lo cierto es que poco a poco este tema
se fue apagando hasta ahora, cuando Maduro
lo ha vuelto a poner sobre la mesa. Y por
eso una pregunta importante que tenemos hacernos
llegados hasta aquí es… ¿Cómo ha sido
realmente la relación de la revolución bolivariana
con esta disputa territorial? ¿Hasta qué
punto este tema le preocupó al Comandante
Chávez?
Pues ojo, porque creo que aquí nos vamos
a llevar muchas sorpresas.
(T2: CHÁVEZ Y GUYANA: LA LUNA DE MIEL QUE
NO FUE)
Queridos, amigos y amigas, para nadie, es
un secreto que Hugo Chávez supuso un antes
y un después en la historia de Venezuela.
La llegada en 1998 de la revolución bolivariana
supuso rehacer por completo todo el sistema
político venezolano.
¿Y sabéis qué? Pese a su conocido discurso
antiimperialista y antioccidental, desde el
comienzo de su gobierno, Hugo Chávez intentó
fraternizar con su vecino guyanés. ¿No me
creéis? Pues fijaos.
C2(“Ha nacido un sentimiento de hermandad
hacia Guyana, que hemos venido a fortalecer
y debo decirles que yo sigo estudiando los
mapas de Guyana, pero no para lanzar paracaidistas
ni meter tanques de guerra, sino para ver
por dónde va a venir la carretera entre Venezuela
y Georgetown, o para ver donde podemos impulsar
proyectos de desarrollo conjunto.” Presidente
Hugo Chávez, 25 de febrero de 2004.
De hecho, Petrocaribe, una alianza creada
en 2005 para permitir a los países caribeños
comprar petróleo venezolano en condiciones
preferentes, fue uno de los instrumentos clave
de la política internacional del socialismo
del siglo XXI. Pues bien, ¿sabéis qué?
Guyana fue uno de los primeros países en
sumarse a esta iniciativa.
N3(23 de enero 2007: Firmado acuerdo de suministro
de hidrocarburos a Guyana-.
El convenio, suscrito en el marco del Acuerdo
de Cooperación Energética Petrocaribe, permitirá
a la vecina nación recibir gasolina, diesel,
jet A1, fuel oil y asfalto, según sus requerimientos.
El suministro establecido representa 50 % del
consumo diario de la nación. PDVSA)
Como veis, de esta forma, Georgetown se convirtió
en energéticamente dependiente de Caracas,
una posición que le daba al gobierno venezolano
una enorme influencia.
C3(“El informe del Banco Central de Guyana
de 2009 registraba una deuda de $143 millones
de dólares (con Venezuela), equivalentes
en ese momento a 15% de la deuda pública
externa, y se esperaba que para 2010 la deuda
ascendiera a $180 millones aproximadamente.
Francine Jácome, Investigadora de la Fundación
Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung)
Pero, pese a todo, el tema del Esequibo nunca
se puso sobre la mesa.
De hecho, Chávez trató a Guyana como si
ambos países fueran víctimas del imperialismo
angloamericano.
(1:21 recuerdo que mi primer contacto con
1:24 Guyana fue en unos planes de guerra
1:30 cuando Venezuela entera había sido
1:34 convertida en un sub Imperio,
+
3:19 nos metieron
3:21 en la cabeza hace muchos años que
3:22 ustedes eran enemigos nuestros imagínate
3:24 tú
3:26 somos hermanos)
Fueron muchos los que entonces denunciaron
que Venezuela estaba perdiendo una oportunidad
histórica para intentar solucionar su vieja
reivindicación territorial.
Unas críticas que fueron a más cuando Guyana
comenzó a buscar petróleo.
N4(6 de junio de 2012: Exploración de crudo
de Guyana reaviva polémica con Venezuela
La oposición venezolana acusó al Gobierno
el miércoles de hacer caso omiso a la exploración
petrolera de Guyana en una región fronteriza
reclamada por Venezuela. Reuters)
Y llegados aquí la gran pregunta es ¿por
qué rayos Hugo Chávez no hizo nada para
intentar recuperar el Esequibo? Pues la cosa
es que el chavismo tenía otras prioridades:
sobre todo su enfrentamiento político con
Colombia.
(De hecho, en 2009, ante la instalación de
bases norteamericanas en territorio colombiano,
Chávez se atrevió a sugerir que se podría
desatar la guerra en la región:
(0:57 Yo cumplo con mi obligación
0:59 moral como jefe de estado presidente
de
1:02 Venezuela y soldado que soy de alertar
1:04 vientos de guerra comienzan a soplar)
Por eso, Chávez buscaba aislar poco a poco
a los países no socialistas de la región,
y para lograrlo intentó convertirse en algo
así como el “suggar daddy” del caribe.
Y eso es exactamente lo que le permitió a
Guyana aprovecharse de la ganga del petróleo
venezolano, al tiempo que Caracas aparcaba
su histórico enfrentamiento.
Irónicamente, el Ministerio de Relaciones
Exteriores venezolano durante toda esta etapa
estuvo a cargo del mismísimo Nicolas Maduro,
que, por supuesto, no se alejaba un milímetro
de la estrategia del líder.
Precisamente por eso, el tema del Esequibo
solo volvió a tomar relevancia cuando en
2013, después de la muerte de Chávez, numerosas
petroleras comenzaron a confirmar la existencia
de yacimientos petroleros en la plataforma
continental de la Guyana Esequiba)
Pese a todo, Maduro no fue más allá de simples
protestas sin más importancia… Hasta que
en la segunda mitad de 2023 de repente ha
estallado una especie de fervor nacionalista
en el gobierno bolivariano.
Y la pregunta es, ¿por qué justo ahora?
¿Qué demonios gana el chavismo haciendo
renacer esta polémica? Pues bien, veámoslo.
(T3: JUGANDO CON FUEGO)
Queridos amigos y amigas, lo cierto es que
el interés del chavismo por reanudar la polémica
con Guyana está lleno de interrogantes. Un
ejemplo de esto lo tenemos en las propias
preguntas del referéndum. Una consulta popular
compuesta por 5 preguntas con una redacción
compleja. Pero de ellas 2 son dos las que
generan inquietud:
C5(3.- ¿Está usted de acuerdo con la posición
histórica de Venezuela de no reconocer la
Jurisdicción de la Corte Internacional de
Justicia para resolver la controversia territorial
sobre la Guayana Esequiba?
P2.- ¿Está usted de acuerdo con la creación
del estado Guayana Esequiba y se desarrolle
un plan acelerado para la atención integral
a la población actual y futura de ese territorio
que incluya entre otros el otorgamiento de
la ciudadanía y cédula de identidad venezolana,
conforme al Acuerdo de Ginebra y el derecho
internacional, incorporando en consecuencia
dicho estado en el mapa del territorio venezolano?
Preguntas del referéndum del 3 de diciembre
de 2023)
Estas dos preguntas le dan al Estado venezolano
un mandato popular de alto riesgo.
En primer lugar, desconocer la Corte Internacional
de Justicia prácticamente deja al conflicto
sin solución diplomática posible. Y es aquí
donde surge el segundo problema, ¿ante la
ausencia de salidas diplomáticas, que es
lo que queda?
Y eso no es todo.
Venezuela se plantea la anexión territorial
del Esequibo, algo que, por supuesto, solo
podría ocurrir mediante el uso de la fuerza.
(11:29 Nosotros vamos a defender nuestros
11:34 derechos sobre la Guyana esquiva en
todos los ámbitos la vamos a defender
11:40 sin caer en provocaciones y sin escuchar
los tambores de la guerra que el presidente
Guyana hoy ha impulsado.)
En Guyana han saltado todas las alarmas. Al
fin y al cabo lo que está en juego es el
74% del territorio de Guyana y la inmensa
mayor parte de una producción petrolera que
no deja de crecer.
N5(14 de noviembre de 2023: Guyana dice ante
CIJ que el referéndum en Venezuela por zona
en disputa es una "amenaza existencial". France
24)
Para los guayaneses lo que está en juego
es mucho más que su extensión territorial.
Y es que veréis, desde que la producción
de crudo guyanés comenzó a despegar en 2015,
el país está experimentando un crecimiento
casi exponencial, hasta el punto de que en
pocos años podría convertirse en el país
más rico de Sudamérica.
Pero, un momento, queridos amigos y amigas
de VisualPolitik, no nos dejemos engañar.
¿Realmente es posible que toda esta artimaña
nacionalista sea por el Esequibo? En principio
esto es algo difícil de creer, porque las
contradicciones están a plena vista:
(32:48 En 2015 donde Guyana asume una posición
beligerante de
32:55 odio contra la República bolivariana
de Venezuela, donde Guyana hace pactos con
33:03 la Exxon Mobile, con el Comando Sur
de los Estados Unidos)
Como veis, según el propio Nicolás Maduro,
el supuesto cambio de actitud de Guyana se
produjo en 2015. Entonces, ¿por qué se esperaron
8 años para protestar tan enérgicamente?
Si esta zona tiene tanto interés para el
chavismo, ¿por qué no intentaros recuperarla
antes cuando las condiciones eran más idóneas?
Pues atentos, porque lo cierto es que aquí
hay gato encerrado.
(18:11 también dispuestos a
18:16 escarmentar a quien se atreva a tocar
un
18:20 metro cuadrado de territorio
18:27 argentino
+
15:49 si quieren venir que vengan
15:53 les presentaremos batalla)
Lo que acabáis de ver es al dictador argentino,
Leopoldo Fortunato Galtieri, celebrando ante
miles de argentinos la recuperación de las
Malvinas en la primera semana de abril de
1982.
Hoy sabemos que la decisión de ocupar las
islas bajo soberanía británica tuvo mucho
que ver con la pérdida de legitimidad de
la dictadura argentina. Digamos que la causa
territorial fue una treta para intentar recuperar
capital político y apoyo social para seguir
en el poder.
¿El resultado? Pues un absoluto desastre.
Los británicos enviaron una fuerza de combate
que expulsó a los argentinos, y aceleró
la caída de la dictadura argentina.
La pregunta es, ¿está el chavismo buscando
generar una situación similar?
(Pues a priori, hay varias diferencias. Primero,
Guyana no es un territorio británico, sino
una nación independiente, por lo que el conflicto
no involucraría a una potencia militar.
En segundo lugar, en un potencial conflicto
militar, la disparidad de fuerzas es enorme.
Venezuela tiene unos 137.000 efectivos por
tierra, mar y aire, mientras que las fuerzas
armadas de Guyana apenas reúnen cerca de
5000 miembros . A pesar de las reconocidas
limitaciones operativas de las FFAA venezolanas,
la escala de competencia es simplemente irreversible
para Georgetown.
Aunque no serían las mismas circunstancias,
el objetivo del chavismo podría ser el mismo
que el de la Junta Militar argentina. Evitar
una apertura democrática a costa de un conflicto
militar que enaltezca una causa nacionalista.
Recordad que tanto la oposición venezolana,
como los EE. UU., están negociando con el
régimen de Maduro la celebración de unas
elecciones limpias en 2024 que, por supuesto,
supondrían la salida del régimen del poder.
Por eso, para muchos analistas, a situación
con Guyana solo busca justificar un estado
de emergencia o de conmoción interna que
congele ese proceso de apertura. También
hay quienes creen que este pasado referéndum
fue un simulacro para engrasar la maquinaria
electoral chavista y testear las alteraciones
del voto electrónico que el chavismo buscaría
emplear para perpetuarse en el poder. Y en
el peor de los casos, la tensión con Guayana
podría darle a Caracas un nuevo comodín
en la negociación con Washington.)
Sea como sea, si algo está claro, es que
en toda esta historia hay un actor que será
clave en como se sucedan los acontecimientos:
estamos hablando, por supuesto, de las fuerzas
armadas venezolanas. La cuestión es que un
estado de semi-guerra o, incluso, un intento
de invasión fortalecería aún más el peso
de los militares en el actual gobierno bolivariano.
(6:19 empeñado estoy en pedirles
6:23 que salgan a votar. Esta no es una
6:28 guerra
6:30 armada, por
6:32 ahora, no es una guerra
6:35 armada)
De momento, el alto mando militar se ha mostrado
comprometido con el tema del Esequibo, la
cuestión es si, a la hora de la verdad, estarían
realmente dispuestos a iniciar un conflicto
armado con el único fin de sostener un proyecto
político que se cae a pedazos.
Quizás piensen que una intervención militar
sería corta por la incapacidad de Guyana
para defenderse. Sin embargo, de intentarlo,
lo más probable es que el conflicto podría
escalar a nivel regional e, incluso, internacional.
C4(Laura Richardson, General del Ejército
de EE. UU. y Comandante del Comando Sur de
EE. UU. (USSOUTHCOM), visitará Guyana del
25 al 27 de julio para reunirse con la Fuerza
de Defensa de Guyana (GDF), la Embajada de
EE. UU. y líderes de la Comunidad del Caribe
(CARICOM) para discutir la asociación de
defensa de EE. UU. con Guyana y los socios
de CARICOM. Embajada de Estados Unidos en
Guyana)
N6(24 de noviembre de 2023: “Vicepresidente
guyanés: Funcionarios de Defensa de EE. UU.
visitarán Guyana en medio de disputa con
Venezuela”. France24)
Este año la cooperación en materia de defensa
entre Georgetown y Washington ha crecido considerablemente.
El hecho de que este país se esté convirtiendo
en una importante potencia petrolera liderada
por la Exxon Mobil es posible que tenga mucha
que ver.
Por eso, aunque en solitario, Guyana no podría
resistir una invasión venezolana, la probabilidad
de que una coalición internacional acuda
en su auxilio no se podría descartar.
Amigos y amigas, el chavismo parece ahora
dispuesto a cruzar una linea roja sumamente
preocupante: provocar una escaramuza militar
en una región donde la guerra ha brillado
por su ausencia. Pero, ¿Qué queréis qué
os diga? Personalmente creo que no estamos
sino ante una nueva cortina de humo para intentar
mejorar su fuerza negociadora y sobre todo
crear un caldo de cultivo que eche abajo cualquier
posibilidad de que se celebren elecciones
libres en 2024.
Sea como sea, las cartas están sobre la mesa.
Pero dicho esto, turno para ti: ¿Conocías
la disputa entre Venezuela y Guayana? ¿Crees
que Caracas podría atreverse a invadir a
su país vecino? Déjanos tu respuesta en
los comentarios y abramos debate. Y ahora,
si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante,
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitk.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.